traumatic video of a plane crash with
the aircraft reportedly carrying the
Wagner group's leader Russian officials
say a private jet leaving the Capitol
for Saint Petersburg went down about 100
kilometers north of Moscow reports
showed the jet was registered to the
Wagner group and that its leader evgeny
progosian was listed as one of the 10
people on board Canada's foreign affairs
minister was questioned about the
development at the federal cabinet
Retreat Wednesday well of course I'll be
able to have access to more information
soon I'll be able to assess the impact
and there will be definitely important
diplomatic conversations particularly
with our allies on the G7 the Kremlin
soldiers fought alongside Wagner
mercenaries in the months-long battle in
Bak moot progojian also led a mutiny
against Russia's military leaders
earlier this summer which ended with him
being exiled to Belarus earlier this
week progosian released his first social
media video since the Mutiny where he
suggested that he was in Africa Kyle
Benning Global News
foreign